the majority of Minneapolis City Council
is pledging to defund or dismantle the
police department following the death of
George Floyd however the city's mayor
Jacob Frye opposes that protesters
chanted go home Jacob over the weekend
after he said he does not support
dismantling the department mayor fries
supports reform and says there needs to
be a culture shift in policing he joins
us from Minneapolis City Hall good
morning mr. mayor
as we said your own City Council
believes the police department can't be
reformed but you still do though you say
the elephant in the room is the police
union what do you mean by that
well let me be exceedingly clear we need
deep structural reform to how the police
department has done business for years
in a way that has failed black and brown
people repeatedly we need a full on
culture shift in terms of the way the
police department does business but mi
fir abolishing the entire department no
I'm not
and yes the elephant in the room is the
police union is the collective
bargaining agreement it's the
arbitration provisions that are set up
that quite literally prevent the chief
and I in many instances from both
disciplining and terminating officers
who have had wrongful conduct if we're
really serious about reform if we're
really serious about changing the game
we need to attack those provisions how
do you do that there's a number of
different mechanisms to make sure that
it happens but so many of these
provisions are deep-seated in state law
there are progressive Chiefs and mayor's
coming before me that have been thwarted
by those provisions and it sets up a
system
it sets up a system where we will
terminate an individual they go through
a long bureaucratic process and then in
some cases as much as a year or
later the initial determination to
terminate or discipline is then reverted
the individual comes back to the police
department the culture does not shift
and there is no accountability we need
changes in state law in some cases we
need changes in city policy but let's be
very clear we do need to go after the
police union many of these instances
because that is where a lot of this
culture has emanated from it needs to
change is it in your view is that the
primary reform that's needed I think
there are many areas of reform that are
needed yes we need to be revamping our
use of force policies but in many
instances were inhibited by state law
yes we do need to make sure that the
accountability matrix is set up so that
when officers have wrongful conduct
there is cut there are consequences but
without attacking these primary modes
you don't get the culture shift because
here's the thing in order to get a
culture shift you do have to to a
certain point focus on personnel and you
can't get those serious personnel
changes without two things one the
ability to get the right officers in and
two the ability to get the wrong
officers out so you know am I for
massive systemic reform absolutely and I
don't want to comment on precisely what
the council meant by disbanding or
ending the police force
I think there's varying opinions but
what I'm saying is look I'm not for
abolishing but deep structural reform
absolutely we have to make it happen
what you you campaigned on reform that's
part of how you got elected you have
reformed the body-cam policy you have
banned warrior training but we still
have the George Floyd incident is reform
enough I mean you've got a city council
a majority that says they want to start
over again well you know you're right in
that the the body camera policy has been
more effective we brought compliance
from 55% to 95% we were the first city
in the nation
ban off-duty warrior style training so
that officers are not deeming someone a
threat until proven otherwise and here's
a big thing we have a chief in chief
Arredondo this is someone who's from
community who literally sued the police
department for racial discrimination and
one
he's chock full of integrity and he's
now our chief he is leading the way in
terms of these massive structural
reforms that we need to see and I want
to be clear
he has my 100% support a full on
recently I mean we care American flavors
and talk about semantics but yes sorry
very quickly we can see if we have CBS
News has learned CBS News Alert that has
learned there was a plea negotiation a
deal between former officer Derek
Chauvin and the county the county
prosecutor and US attorneys at office
but that that broke down before charges
were filed were you aware of that no I
was not aware of the details of that no
okay so you're sure you're not aware of
any negotiations at all that occurred no
we're not involved in the prosecution or
the investigation you know the pieces
that we were involved in is you know as
soon as we found out we said it was
absolutely heinous and wrong in every
sense to we fired the officers and as
mr. mayor and then three I called for
charges and I think that's something
that we need to start doing too is it's
the honest and we need to acknowledge
the truth all right mr. mayor mayor
jacob frye thank you so much for being
with us this morning